how the fuck you making you nervous he's
running
[Music]
30 and 31 out of that one
i mean just you know maybe just try to
keep it down a little bit
yeah
you guys live over here
i'm going to show you my idea oh i don't
care yeah sure if you want me show you
my idea yeah
right
yeah that's right she took too fucking
long drunk
you're good
you're good
[Music]
they see the police here they ain't
pulling over they think y'all stealing
that drunk shit yeah
you living you live on orange can i see
it you know my eyes down the street
who does that i said my heart stays
right down the street oh does she i stay
i'm gonna tell you if you're valid oh i
know i'm valid let's see
trust me not that you're driving so it
don't matter
oh don't matter you ain't driving
or not no no show me i want to see i
know for a fact let me see you
restricted but you're veiled restrict
the words i restricted that no no no
you're failing
i'm saying d restricted
so you got like glasses or something
yeah but my license is illegal
it's valid yeah yeah i know foreign
all right
oh you got three warrants though
[Music]
all right
[Music]
still looks like he's got something
bulging out of the front you guys good
got the liquor though
what's up what's the big bulge in the
front of his pants though
there's a big bulge in front of his
pants what is that i don't even know his
belt
why is he walking away oh tell him tell
him to step on the sidewalk real quick
in the roger shirt
with his girlfriend i might add a little
bit of too much to drink i don't know
i do i just want to make sure everyone's
safe pull up here you see the cops i
know i know i think they had something
oh
your boy's making me nervous though
who's making you nervous
how the fuck making you nervous he's
running
we got one dipping out in a roger's
green jersey he's got a gun in the front
of his waistband stop
stop
he's going eastbound he's going he's
bound to the next street
he's got white pants green jersey number
12.
left here
shot fire just fired
[Applause]
shots fired he's still going eastbound
he shot at me he's running eastbound
i'm good
eastbound
green jersey
white pants
eastbound
[Applause]
all right just go green jersey now
radio i took four shots at him
as he was running shooting at me
all right what's your call son
radio's problem 5 22.
he ran into the brush
i believe i'm on
lemon
let me catch my breath
great
and it's gonna be
peach street
between raven peach
guys be careful you rip shots at me
[Music]
hi
[Music]
right
go that way go that way oh right here
right here to the right
olivia call it out
next one down
roof
are you shot
are you shot i got him radio
keep your hands on the other side
radio 522
olivia call the address out
i got one male in custody he had white
shorts on he's in the tank top he might
have ditched the hoodie i have him in
custody
are you shocked
get up
hello
are you shot are you injured i need you
to answer me
he's not answering me
but he won't get up
hey we're good here find that hoodie in
the gun
he came right over this fence here threw
this brush the next one down
get up
let's go
[Applause]
uh
uh
[Music]
no i seen him right come through this
brush right here so look through here
[Music]
lean forward
yeah whoever you got if you want to
bring around the peachtree i'll tell you
if that's the right guy
[Music]
he started shooting at me as he was
heading east to the